hi uh good morning and I'm extremely
honored to introduce uh Pam Samuelson
who will give us the first talk uh this
morning on large language models meeting
copyright law and um uh I think there's
nobody in the world who's a bigger
expert so we're extremely lucky uh to
hear from you on this topic and Sam is
the and and Pam is the uh is a she's a
distinguished professor of law at UC
Berkeley law school and also in the high
school and she's the director ctor of a
center on technology and law and um
she's just very recently written an
article whose title is generative AI
meets copyright so uh extremely um
honored to have you here and interested
to hear your talk and after the talk
there'll be a panel on topics that have
to do with copyright privacy other uh
bias uh a lot of topics connected with
data which has been a central focus of
this Workshop but the importance of data
thank you
[Music]
py thanks for the invitation to
participate in this uh Workshop I'm uh
I've been writing about um l technology
since the uh mid 1980s um and
interacting with people in the Computing
field has actually been something that's
been very gratifying for me over the
years um and so even though I don't have
a technical background myself um uh I've
been writing a regular call for
communications to the ACM uh about uh
law and Technology issues uh and spoken
at a bunch of conferences and and the
like but um uh part of my role in life
is actually to try
be a um a conduit right a bridge between
communities that don't usually talk to
each other but um uh when it comes to
generative AI I think it's really
important to understand uh that the law
is going to have something to say about
what you guys are doing and uh so uh
having at least some understanding about
what are the lawyers talking about what
are the terms of discourse uh might
actually be something that would be
helpful to you as you kind of go forward
let address three principal questions
today uh when of it all is making copies
of copyrighted works as training data uh
infringe uh copyright in those Works uh
when if at all are AI generated
outputs infringing derivative Works uh
and when if at all is the removal or
alteration of what's called copyright
management information that's associated
with copies of Works uh does that
violate a copyright related rule all
three of these questions are being
addressed uh in the litigations that are
going on right now uh and all three are
also going to be likely topics uh for a
study that the copyright office uh is
going to probably be writing sometime uh
in the next year I thought it would be
helpful to get started by there are 10
lawsuits out there right now in the
United States and there's a couple of
plant also in uh in Europe but I'm going
to concentrate on US law but I will take
questions about International
implications of this stuff um if uh and
when you're interested in it so um uh uh
stability is the defendent in two
lawsuits one by Getty Images uh which
says that uh that uh the 12 million
Getty Images that uh stable diffusion
was uh um uh the model was trained on
that that actually uh isn't infringement
and it's in common with the Anderson
case so the Anderson case is actually
what's known as a class action that say
uh Anderson is basically the the name
plet but purports to represent the
interests of all uh visual artists whose
Works have been uh trained uh for uh
stable diffusion uh and both these
lawsuits say that the training data
copies are uh infringement and that
outputs are infringing derivative works
okay so that's that's the sort of the
main claims in that particular case but
there's also what I'm calling a 122
violation that's the thing about
removing or altering copyright
management information and I'll give you
an example of that later um uh open AI
more recently has been uh the subject of
two class action lawsuits and that's
apparently on behalf of all authors
whose Works were used as training data
so it Focus focuses a lot on books but
actually if you look at what the class
definition is they basically say we're
representing all authors whose stuff got
uh copied uh and the claims are really
the same as the ones in the uh the
stability cases meta more recently also
was sued for copyright infringement and
122 violations and there's a more recent
lawsuit against alphabet uh now most of
these lawsuits all but the the Getty
lawsuits are actually brought by the
same Law Firm so one lawyer is basically
trying to kind of get a monopoly on this
uh uh on this particular thing um uh but
there's a second uh another lawsuit also
a class action but brought by a
different uh a different um a different
set of
lawyers uh but um so those the six
lawsuits on copyright uh open AI GitHub
and Microsoft resuit for uh not for
copyright infringement although the
complaint says oh terrible massive uh
copyright but um uh but they basically
say that the uh that the use of the open
source programs to train the Codex llm
which then uh is used to
uh essentially utter some uh code uh for
the um uh for the uh for the co-pilot um
uh and so the open- source licenses in
122 are the basis of the of those
particular lawsuits and um interestingly
the uh the plff in that case are are
John do right people who are programmers
whose stuff was used uh but they claim
that actually uh they get death threats
if they uh if they're named um because
some people um are are uh upset about
them bringing this particular lawsuit
open AI has also been uh uh sued for
privacy and some are related towards and
then there are two other lawsuits which
are narrower in context but they um uh
one is focused on right of publicity
violations and one on data Privacy Law
so that's what those are the 10 lawsuits
and I'm happy to answer questions more
specifically about them um as a uh as
you get interested in it it's important
to understand that the lawsuits are not
the only thing that's going on here so
members of Congress have actually held
uh a set of hearings and probably there
will be more hearings uh going forward
uh and some of the witnesses have called
for legislative change um one proposal
is collective licensing for uses of
works that are training data um to
address kind of celebrity impersonations
and other kinds of fakes there's a
proposal for some legislation on that um
and there are couple of other things
that are on the table but the copyright
office held a set of what they call
listening sessions uh this spring and
all the uh all the videos and all the
witness statements uh are up on the
copyright office website if you want to
uh take a look at it um uh and they
focused on different types of uh
different types of works but the point
is that most of the copyright owners who
testified at this at these things
Furious about Jenner Deale just
unbelievably Furious um uh and um So
based on what was said at those uh at
those meetings uh the office plans to
issue what they call a notice of inquiry
basically they they pose a bunch of
questions and then they say please
anybody who's interested answer those
questions what I'm going to say to you
is like a real really really big mistake
not to put something in because the
copyright office is going to base its
report on what it gets in response to
the notice of inquiry so if all the AI
people basically sit and say oh I don't
have to do anything about this because
those people are so ignorant they
shouldn't you know they shouldn't be
allowed to make any kind of judgments
like guess what um they're going to do
something and you want your voice to
actually be heard uh there so the office
will eventually publish a report and may
make recommendations to Congress about
legislation or the like did you have a
question when you say stakeholder
perspectives here what do you mean sorry
when you say a stakeholder perspective
who are stakeholders in this well most
of the people who were uh who were
participating um were uh were people
representing authors or um some of them
were individual authors some of them
were working for companies or for um so
it wasn't just one one-sided right open
AI sent somebody stability sent somebody
uh so um there were Representatives but
um there weren't very many there were a
few academics uh that were interested in
a few who were computer science uh
computer scientists and a few uh that
were law people U but anybody who wanted
to toh speak could actually have asked
for um for uh for a chance to be on the
panel um but that's
the whole point was that they they
recognized that there are multiplicity
of interests there uh and wanted to uh
at least hear from people who and give
them an opportunity to vent right in
some sense that's part of what's going
on so um uh so that's actually the on
the policy front that's going to be
really important now you sort of say why
are they bringing these lawsuits well uh
one motivation for the lawyers is that
if you win a class action lawsuit you
can win a lot of money right um because
class usually what happens is that on a
class action lawsuit like these where
people like Sarah Anderson you know
she's a visual artist but she ain't
exactly Rich uh so what's going to
happen is the the guy who's basically
the law the lawyer who's uh in charge of
the lawsuit um he's gonna basically bet
the bank that he's going to win this
lawsuit and when he wins that lawsuit he
can get up to a third of the recovery
and in the in the in the the lawsuit
against G GitHub uh they're asking uh
this lawyer is asking for n billion
dollar um and so we're talking billions
here because of statutory damages which
I'll talk about in a little while um so
but in addition to the money okay the
class action lawyers love uh things that
have be associated with them um uh they
obviously are you know it's a it's kind
of a burnish your reputation to like set
a new president uh and attracts new
clients and the like uh but you can't
just bring a lawsuit because you want to
to get money right you have to have some
people who are actually unhappy enough
that they're willing to subject
themselves to being uh Plains in a
lawsuit uh and so you sort of say there
are a lot of authors um the only
relatively famous one is Sarah Silverman
right now uh but who knows who else will
uh be um uh attracted to the idea of
participating but authors visual artists
songwriters script writers and
programmers there are lots of them out
there who object to uh essentially the
use of their works as training data you
didn't ask permission you're not
compensating us uh the only reason that
the the systems actually produce high
quality outputs is because you built the
models on our stuff right if you built
it on garbage then all it would utter is
garbage uh but you the reason is so high
quality is because our stuff is high
quality and therefore you owe us right
there's a kind of unjust enrichment uh
nature to the claims um and it also
irritates some people that you know this
is a big corporations basically taking
stuff for free and then uh
commercializing it and you know some
people think that well that's capitalism
and some people think that's not fair
okay so that's kind of what's going on
and if you want a kind of graphic
representation of
how they feel okay and again the graphic
artists are really good at having a kind
of um ability to show through their
Graphics how upset they are about stuff
so this is actually the um I've I've
seen quite a few cartoons about this
this is the best one uh so far um okay
so I think it's actually important to
recognize that this the the kind of the
the upsettedness by about um uh by a lot
of these people um is part of what I'm
going to call a larger moral Panic right
now about generative
AI obviously you know better than I do
about the the open letter asking for a
six-month pause I don't think anybody
actually did that but um uh but you know
it was a call I was kind of recognizing
that there's stuff going on nationally
and internationally there are
conversations about how to regulate uh
uh AI period and generative AI in
particular uh and one commentary um
characterized generative AI is this
Marxist nightmare because the work of
millions of authors is accruing to a few
capitalist owners who pay nothing at all
for all of that labor so you see that
there's actually part of the moral Panic
is you're going to put me out of
business right that that when it comes
to something like stable uh stable
diffusion that people are going to go
and uh and use stable diffusion to get
graphic art rather than hiring a visual
artist and so they're really worried
about their livelihood authors are
worried about uh about you you know that
the script writers WR are having a kind
of moral Panic about um uh the use of AI
to um
uh scripts and and the like so this is
actually really important that it
motivates a lot of the kind of anger
right so that I mean they're upset for
one thing but underlying their
upsettedness is I think this broader
Panic
okay okay copyright on nutshell so
copyright attaches automatically by
operation of L uh from the first
fixation of an original work in some
tangible form um and it lasts for a
really long time uh and the two rights
that we're going to focus on today are
the exclusive right to control
reproductions of your work and copies
and also to make derivative works lasts
a long time it only protects the
original expression in the works uh uh
but um uh it's limited by fair use and
some other doctrines really important
thing to understand is that if they they
win on these lawsuits uh there's a lot
of money that can be made in terms of
those compensatory and uh discouragement
Awards uh statutory damages uh is
another type of Remedy and injunctions
are important and they courts have the
power to impound and Order destruction
of infringing stuff uh so these uh large
language models could get uh vaporized
in so far as they're they're based on uh
stuff that isn't licensed or public
domain fair use is a a limitation on the
scope of these exclusive rights um and
as a defense to a charge of infringement
courts consider four factors in deciding
whether used is fair or not the purpose
and character of The Challenge used uh
and the statue basically identifies uh
criticism comment news teaching research
and scholarship as among the kind of
favored uses right uh and non-commercial
over commercial uh and since
1994 uh it's mattered quite a bit
whether the whether the the challenged
use is
transformative um and transformative has
come to be uh standing for um a pretty
wide range of things that that that
people can do with other people's work
so the canonical example is a parody
right so a parody will basically um uh
transform some of the expression from
the original work in order to make fun
of it uh and then uh if you didn't take
too much then that's probably going to
be fair use but uh increasingly when the
defendants work has a different purpose
from the original that can actually be
treated as transformative too and I'll
give a couple examples in a
minute cours also take into account uh
the nature of the copyrighted work and
so um uh so some things are said to be
nearer to the core of copyright um and
some things are farther away so software
generally out here um because it's got a
lot of functional content uh things that
are kind of artistic and fanciful uh
tend to get sort of uh kind of closer to
the to the heart of copyright uh and so
that kind of is a factor sometimes in um
uh in kind of weighing whether something
is uh is bad or not unsurprisingly the
amount and substantiality of the taking
is a factor um uh uh and then the effect
of the challenge use on the market for
the value of the work and generally
speaking the purpose and and and Market
effects factors tend to dominate there
those those are the ones that that make
the most difference now when it comes to
to ingesting uh in copyright works as
training data um um there are several
precedents that actually um are what the
generative AI companies are really uh
relying on um one is a case called f
versus Google where uh uh F basically
puts some of his work up on the Internet
um and Google then uh B basically made
copies of it and uh in the web web
crawling and then indexed the uh and
cached the the copies and the court
decided that that was a transformative
fair use right so field put up uh the
the the the material on the internet for
people to
read and Google basically copied it for
a different purpose right uh and so even
though it was a an exact copy was made
um it was transformative because it was
for a different purpose similarly in the
author SC be Google case um I'm
sorry so so uh one could say if I
understood right field put it up for
people to look at and Google made it
easier for people to look at it so
couldn't one say that Google was
actually um you know working to to uh
enhance what what field wanted rather
than working against field yes so I
think that's I think that's another
consideration in the case it wasn't one
of the things that the court focused on
but yeah I think it's a consideration
it's it's a clear example that is the is
the Google Books case right which I'm
going to talk about now so Google
basically um as you know uh copied
somewhere between 20 and 30 million
books out of research Library
collections including out of the UC
system um I think three million books
out of the UC libraries um and uh the
oh copyright infringement copyright
infringement um but the court basically
said look they digitized the the text of
that for the purpose of indexing and
serving up Snippets and the Snippets
were small enough uh uh parts of the
work that it couldn't basically um
supplant demand for the original right
the supplant the demand for the original
is kind of a a very common phrase in uh
in copyright land uh and so basically
said again
transformative even though you copi the
whole thing you can't index the contents
if you don't copy the whole thing and so
Google's copying then was reasonable in
light of its transformative purpose and
since the Snippets didn't supplant
demand for the
original um then uh the court decided it
was fair use yeah other computational
users how do they Define that because
I'm sorry that phrase other comp
computational uses that yeah Thats So
the the second Circuit Court of Appeals
took into account uh that Google was
making other uses besides just Snippets
and um uh Snippets and and indexing
right that they were they were enabling
other things so the engram viewer for
example was identified as something that
was a was kind of another use and uh so
there is this thing there's okay another
thing that lawyers like really like
focus on is is something a holding of a
case or is it what we call
dicta dicta is something that the court
says but it's not core part of the
holding so the second circuit talks
about computational uses as like a good
thing what's dict that's good dictum
it's dicta is from Latin just means said
right a statement essentially something
that the that a court says you know I
actually point to dicta all the time
when I'm writing papers or writing amus
briefs but um you have to lawyers always
have to like Focus what's the holding of
the Google Books case it is that making
copies of books for the purpose of
indexing their contents and serving up
Snippets that's fair use no but you say
as well as other computational users I'm
just saying I'm now I'm see I'm now I'm
being La okay so the holding of the case
is about indexing and caching the court
talks about other computational uses in
a positive way but that's
dicta oh doesn't doesn't get the weight
right if you kind of like say what's the
precedent right what is the holding of
the case that's the holding of the case
and this is some dicta that people who
are representing these generative AI
companies they're going to look to that
language and say oh you see second
Circuit Court of Appeals uh said that
that's a that's a good thing dict is
fluff I'm sorry dicta is fluff no no no
it's taken seriously it just doesn't
have precedential weight okay so that's
I'm I'm I'm doing a little lost school
class today here um okay so it's not
flop at all um uh taken very seriously
but somebody who's fighting against the
generative AI companies will say the
holding in that case was Y and they
didn't actually make a ruling about the
computational uses
okay anyway there's another case uh uh
in which a couple of students uh brought
a lawsuit against a company that makes a
uh DET uh plagiarism detection software
um and the lawsuit was really a bogus
lawsuit um and the court threw it out U
but uh the court the sort of the
question was whether the storage of the
student paper um right if you're trying
to build a plagiarism detection system
you want to have lots of papers and and
so uh they were kind of ran these uh
papers through to see whether these
students actually plagiarized but then
they stored them and uh the court
decided that was a different purpose
therefore it was transformative so even
though they copied the whole thing um it
was uh it was fair use okay in the
Google Books case how did the Court
decide that the demand was not
supplanted was
it was it done on average yeah well the
it's easy to find that decision on the
internet um and I could spend actually
the rest of the time talking about that
but um the court basically said you can
only get three Snippets it's only this
many words long um and they took into
account that Google basically had uh not
done um the sarus es and dictionaries
and other things where there might be a
greater risk of supplanting Banas the
orig but the court recognize that in
general people are not going to go to to
the Google search engine in order to to
read the contents of a book um uh and
one of the things that um uh an
organization that I'm affiliated with
called a Alliance uh did a um sub anas
brief in support of Google's fair use
defense because our authors want their
work to be found right and so it had
this kind of information locating for
the public benefit um that the court
took into account right again part of
the part of what's going on in copyright
also is this kind of like there is this
kind of constitutional purpose of
copyright which is to promote the
progress of science um and so things
that basically provide a public benefit
um uh are seen as you know you can't do
everything and say oh it's a public
benefit to put it up on the internet uh
but uh in cases like this that can
actually be a significant
consideration one of the the key topic
now is St overflow where people answer
questions would that be like the sorus
or dictionary in the sense that if AI
replace that it would violate the the
standard um if you just give me a little
chance I'm gonna go I'm gonna go through
some things that that will will I think
come close to answering that question
and then maybe you can ask it after I've
I've sort of done some other things I'm
I'm trying to get through fair use right
now um so anyway um in the plagiarism
case how did the company get the student
papers oh the the schools actually
required the students to submit their
papers they to the company I see
thanks how much trust they had in their
students right um okay so um one of the
things that uh that that people will say
is that in the field in the author Guild
case Google was making it easier for
people to find the copyrighted
works and what the uh what the stable
diffusion does is makes it easier for
users to produce images that compete
with the ingested images or at least
that's the way that um the law was
Lawyers are probably going to have to
try to do it and then this kind of like
not fair thing and um uh the the author
skilled um you know did a survey and
said 90% of our authors think that uh uh
the company should pay for ingesting our
work as training data and of course as
you know there are some markets emerging
for um licensing of ingestion um uh one
thing actually that the the Silverman
complaint does is um uh talk about you
know that open AI was trained on a
corpus of pired books right so if
there's infringing stuff out there on
the internet uh and you train on that um
that might actually sort of sour your
fair use defense because you didn't kind
of get lawful access to the works um and
um the you know if you train your stuff
on scub wow that would be really cool
wouldn't it but you know what that's
illegal stuff and so that could actually
be um cut against fair use I'm not
saying it can't be fair use um I have a
colleague um Mike Carol who wrote a long
article that basically said that
training on um well the one implication
of which is training on something like
scub might actually be
but uh but I'm just saying these are
these are considerations that might kind
of cast out on the the sort of the the
viability of fair use defenses uh it's
also possible that courts will treat
diffusion differently than the large
language models um uh because here's the
here's the ingested image you kind of
put some noise in there and then there's
H the output kind of you Denise it that
kind of sounds like you copied it and
then you kind pretended dude didn't copy
it and then uh and then it comes out and
so there's kind of that is GNA that
could be a basis for treating it
differently than large language models
uh because I think llms are more
abstract than um than the diffusion but
I don't know I'm not a technical person
um it's also possible that courts could
decide to treat software different than
music or um the like and I tell you
something the music
industry there are no meaner people on
the face of the Earth um than the people
from um the recording industry of
America um uh anyway the point is that
the the there are lots of ways in which
these uh uh these factors could cut
against somebody yeah so in in in
general historically there has been
precedent for treating different
modalities
musics
video I'm not predicting this I'm just
trying to open your mind to the fact
that there could be some differences uh
and part of it is that you know who is
organized and who is got a lot of money
to uh so the visual artists actually are
not in a very good shape because they
don't have any they don't really have
you know they're like little little
organizations of visual artists but
they're not like a big Collective right
um whereas in the music industry you
have lots of players that are kind of uh
concentrated um uh in uh small small
number of hands and so they just tend to
be more active in copyright land so the
um but uh this is just you know I'm kind
of trying to give you some of the
landscape right give you a little feel
for what's going on um so another sort
of consideration is Market harm right um
so uh Getty says we have an established
uh market for licensing use of our
images as training data um and uh and so
one question is you know stability's use
of of those images as training data did
that harm the market well I think their
claim of unfairness is that you know
that's a little bit dicey and it
wouldn't surprise me if that case ends
up with a a settlement because um the
market harm argument is uh strong if you
have an existing market and you didn't
you know and you didn't pay for it you
just uh decided to take it for free um
yeah
so uh I don't understand how stability
got hold of the G images are they using
like little snapshots or it is my
understanding uh that uh that what was
used was um uh was
URLs okay so direct URLs you can access
the IM you can see preview images of
Getty water yes preview images I'm gonna
show you some images okay oh hold on
um okay so now so I think Getty has a
has a better claim than Anderson because
Anderson is just one visual artist and
right now she's the only named plain in
that particular case and she couldn't
possibly give a license to uh uh ingest
uh for training data um for all the
visual artists right she don't she don't
repres she hasn't been certified as a uh
as a class uh and so she can't Grant a
li and so so essentially there's a kind
of market failure argument there as to
uh as to Anderson Reddit has now
announced that anyone who uses a Reddit
post needs training needs uh a license
um uh even though Reddit doesn't
actually own copyright in the post
because those are basically owned if
anybody if anything by the people who
wrote them um uh but now if a generative
AI developer uh uses readit um uh does
that mean that that's unfair and what
about you know before they had a market
set up um you know if you trained in is
that are you are you Scot free or now do
you have to go back and negotiate so
these are just some considerations that
will be part of the uh part of what
people will be fighting about in court
another kind of idea that's floating out
there a lot is um the idea of a
collective license
uh so Collective license would be
something that Congress could pass some
legislation that basically says hey um
uh you know here's a generative AI
companies should have to pay a certain
amount of money into a pot and then
we'll sort of allocate that money to
people this actually strikes me as a
really really really bad idea um but um
uh but a lot of the people who are upset
about um uh who are upset about of AI um
they uh actually uh are kind of like oh
yeah let's do
that um it's a bad idea because trying
to administer something um like this
would be just uh a a a practical
nightmare so practically is a about um
transaction costs um are huge um how
much would everybody whose stuff was gen
was uh was gen uh was
uh used as training data how much would
you get you won't get a dime you
wouldn't get like maybe a penny um and
how much would it cost to basically set
up a payment system now of course um
some of the people who are representing
the authors and the artists and so forth
they want billions right um but you know
there has to be some middle ground and
you know you're going to set up a an
international agency um how do you kind
of you see what I'm saying the
Practical
privac
yeah anyway if you think it's a good
idea go for it sorry can I can I ask a
Qui question um so so you mentioned
billions um but if if AI is going to be
a substantial fraction of the economy in
five 10 years yeah shouldn't it be
trillions well so there are lots of
issues out there um uh and the question
of whether or not some of the companies
that are making AI Technologies should
um provide some support for other
sectors of the uh uh of the world um
including people um I think there's a
good argument for that uh but uh I do
think that um right
now copyright is the name of the
game and copyright is not about
protecting the livelihoods of individ
ual creators okay that's just not what
we're about um it's a limited Monopoly
that's intended to uh do a certain job
which is create incentives for people to
invest in making new things and sharing
them with the world and so when when
courts uh are asked to use copyright to
protect privacy or to protect against
defamation or other things basically the
courts basically say out um uh that copy
you have to be harmed in the way that
copyright
law concern is concerned with right and
so these larger considerations about
sort of the future of work and so forth
really super important but it's not
copyright's job to solve them okay so in
some sense what we have is this is the
tool right now that's out there that
could have a substantial impact and the
question is should we be thinking
uh about a larger governance uh
framework and I think yeah the answer to
that is yes but um in the meantime
copyright's just got to do its job and
and so that's part of what I'm
struggling with is try to soort to say
you know what can copyright law do and
what copyright law can't do um and so
Collective license is one of those ideas
out there that some people are very fond
of so um I've sort of been giving you
reasons to doubt the the the fair use
but um but there are these kind of
counterveiling
considerations uh so uh in general
people who are developing these systems
are not interested in the expression in
the work they're interested in the work
of data um and essentially as I
understand it uh essentially the the you
know documents are bags of words and raw
material for certain kinds of
computational uses that will then allow
you to sort of get some inferences that
you would be able to get it otherwise um
and lots of things that uh that that are
contained in copyrighted works are not
within the scope of protection that
copyright law provides uh and in so far
as the generative AI enables creative uh
uh things to happen you could say that's
kind that's kind consistent with the
Constitutional purpose of copyright uh
and one of the other things that Fause
is said to do is kind of provide some
breathing room right so you don't want
to give so many rights to the first
generation copyright owner so that it
basically squelches the ability of
people to build on uh existing works so
the kind of the breathing space is
another one of the kind of memes in
copyright land um so what is expression
in a
work uh obviously the the you know the
sequences of words and text and so forth
so but there's also kind of what uh is
called kind of the structure of uh of of
work sometimes can be protected um and
so infringement happens when a defendant
work is substantially similar in
expression and that the defendant
improperly appropriated that expression
from the from the copyrighted work uh
and uh sometimes you kind of do a kind
of lay Observer what what would a lay
Observer or think and now I'm going to
give you some images and uh so um here
is an example of uh s Steinberg's poster
um familiar to many of us uh and uh
Colombia pictures decided to use a
poster um and uh you can see that there
are lots of differences between the
Steinberg poster and this one but there
are a lot of similarities too and uh the
trial judge decided that actually uh it
was substantially similar enough to to
be an infringement of the Steinberg
poster I think another consideration is
this is a Motion Picture company they're
used to clearing rights if they wanted
to use th Steinberg's uh poster they
should have paid for it right um and so
there was uh there's kind of this is a
derivative work of the of the uh of the
poster and uh and so uh the court
decided that that was that was an
infringement but what I'm uh what I was
trying to say here is some Works
especially artistic and fancy ones are
highly expressive right they have lots
and lots of expression in them and not
very much unprotectable stuff um uh
other works um uh have a smaller amount
of expression in them and contain a lot
more uh unprotectable stuff and so they
have a thinner scope of copyright and
part of what courts tried to do is
filter out the unprotect bles before
they um before they make a decision
about infringement so here is an exam
here's a list of the unprotectable
elements in copyrighted Works um and uh
here's an example of a case to where it
mattered so ho and tblo were both
engineering professors at Northwestern
and um uh a graduate student named Chang
worked first for uh for ho and during
the time he was there ho developed a new
mathematical model of how electrons
behave
uh under certain circumstances Chang
then went to work for tblop um uh and
tblop and Chang published a paper and a
book chapter about the model and used
equations figures text from um uh from
Ho's writings and ho's paper was
rejected about the model because it had
been preempted by the TL paper um so you
can see from the standpoint of academic
misconduct this is a you know Tabo is a
creep
but uh but was tavl um uh did tavl
infringe copyright well I brought the
lawsuit you copied my equations my
equations are really really creative
took a lot of effort and took a lot of
you know uh intellectual effort and blah
blah blah but guess what model was an
idea and the equations and the figures
and other things that were used uh in
the Tav love paper were the only
practical ways to express the model's
idea and under um uh one of the
prominent Supreme Court president Baker
be Seldon uh Court said not protected by
copyright law so here's the famous uh
statement and I'm giving you this
because this actually has some relevance
to the generative AI stuff right the
copyright of a work on a mathematical
science cannot give the author an
exclusive right to the methods of
operation which he propounds or the
diagrams he employs to explain them so
as to prevent an engineer from using
them whenever the occasion required the
very object of a book on science uh is
to communicate to the world the useful
knowledge it contains but this object
would be frustrated if the knowledge
could not be used without incurring the
guilt for piracy of the book and where
an art it teaches can't be used without
employing the methods the methods and B
and the diagrams are are necessary
incidents to the art and given there
withth to the public okay so this is a
again a statement that um that that kind
of is py about sort of what copyright
does and doesn't protect and
and yeah could you explain how is this
is different from the New Yorker cover
which also seems like it's the idea of
of this of this map of the world that
that is being uh being Tak how how is
that not the thing that's so copyright
is really really
really important to say that that that
methods aren't protective right so
artistic stuff right Saul Steinberg's
kind of like
conception is Artistic but it's an idea
it's artistic and courts give a broader
scope of copyright protection to things
that are artistic okay when it comes to
this stuff okay you don't need to use
the Sol Steinberg thing right um if you
want to write about the mathematical
model in the H tlock case you got to be
able to use the stuff the science is
basically not gonna Advance if oh I
can't I can't talk about this thing or I
have to like I have to say it completely
differently well that doesn't make any
sense right so Court the courts have
been very clear that this kind of stuff
and facts um theories all kinds of
things unprotected by copyright law the
more you're in a non-fiction space uh
the more the the thinner the scope of
the copyright so equations aren't
artistic what equations are not artistic
from the standpoint of copyright law
absolutely
not so the fact that you guys think
they're beautiful I don't you know I
think that's great okay but I just
telling you we're in we're in copyright
land right now okay and copyright land
is a different space um so yes yeah
there was actually um a fight in the
Google versus Oracle case about um a
statement that I think it was a uh
Joshua block made um about how artistic
um the design of the Java API was and
boy did Oracle try to melt that one for
all its worth and uh the court basically
didn't
buy so in this case if ho had used some
artistic rendition to better communicate
his ideas that would be more likely to
be protected under copyright rather than
the equations that are literally useful
for describing is that the idea here
yeah I mean again there are sometimes a
little blurry lines um but when you're
talking about
equations equations are basically way
outside the scope of copyright okay and
figures little more iffy text a little
more iffy but the court will basically
say did you really need to use this in
order to express the idea and in that
particular case all the stuff was that
was said to be the basis of infringement
was stuff that the court said was
unprotected by copyright law okay I'm
Gonna Keep I'm gonna actually go on
because I um I I'm seeing that the hour
is going uh so can a generative uh AI uh
infringe the derivative work right the
answer is yes um uh this is the way that
the term derivative work is uh defined
in the statute a work based on one or
more pre-existing work and then it gives
a set of nine examples and I've given
you a few of them here uh translations
musical Arrangements condensation um uh
um Motion Picture version Etc or any
other form in which a work may be recast
transformed or adapted uh so um uh it's
not enough for something to be based
upon it has to have drawn
some expression from the first work and
used it in the second work okay so can
can they infringe the answer is yes um
these are examples of images that uh
were put into um um uh mid Journey um
and uh you want I want Snoopy with a
with the Christmas decorations and the
uh and the little um dogghouse um and
this is what you get Snoopy is Artistic
and therefore gets a broadc protection
so these could potentially uh infringe
uh but then the question is who's the
infringer right so in general there's a
distinction in copyright between a
direct and an indirect infringer right
if I make a copy of something then I'm
going to be the direct infringer um but
um sometimes a third party can be held
um if they have the right inability to
control the infringing conduct uh
conduct and they enjoy a financial
benefit um from the infringement and
several of the uh generative AI lawsuits
um are
claiming that um these systems are
indirect infringers um the other CA the
defendants in these cases are looking to
the Sony betamax and um the groer
decisions by the Supreme Court uh which
have held that a technology developer is
not an indirect infringer if it makes
and sells technology that has
substantial non-infringing
uses okay so even if you know that some
people are going to use it to
infringe the public has a right to get
access to the technology for its
non-infringing uses uh so um that's an
important uh consideration and so you
know you could say that when it comes to
the Snoopy thing the the people who put
who asked for the Snoopy thing they're
Direct infringers and if mid Journey
didn't kind of Define the system in
order to like make these infringing
copies uh somebody just use it for
infringing purposes they may be able to
say hey Sony betamax um I have a
technology that's a non-infringing use
okay uh there can be a link between the
input and the output um so if outputs
infringe the derivative work right that
might affect how courts feel about the
ingestion issue um and so there's a case
um uh that was about um Accolade made
video games it one of those games to run
on a Sega platform um in order to uh to
be able to do that uh revers engineered
the code to get access to interface
information it then
reimplemented um uh the interface in uh
non-infringing code and uh Sega sued for
infringement not based on the video
games as they were um uh as they were
sold in the market but based on the uh
on the reverse engineering and the court
decided that was that because the
interface was not protectable by
copyright law was not part of the works
expression as part of The Works
unprotectable Elements um uh then uh it
was the reverse engineering to get
access to that interface information was
lawful but the court sort of implied
that if they' gone in to try to get some
expression from the program and then uh
reimplemented that that that might make
the reverse engineering not fair okay so
that's just another one of the kind of
things that are out there um uh and um
but I think in general uh text images
and other things that get uh generated
in response to user prompts are not
going to be substantially similar in
expression the way that copyright law
cares about um and in so far as that's
true then the outputs are unlikely to
infringe the derivative work right um
and the Anderson case basically um makes
the claim that all outputs of stable
diffusion are infringing derivatives
because they're all based
upon uh the training data and the court
threw that out said no you got to have
substantial similarity in in expression
so here's the output if I can match
expression from that output to
particular inputs
then I can make a derivative work claim
but otherwise not okay um and uh one
complaint in the complaint against
GitHub there's a a mention of a study
that found co-pilot suggest code
matching training data in one% of the
outputs I think 1% is probably pretty
small but um uh it's one of those things
that courts are going to have to take
into example uh or take into uh
consideration Getty basically put this
image uh in its complaint um claiming
that this is substantially similar now I
think you can say there is some sub
substantial similarity between these two
things but not in the
expression okay it's not enough that
they're both basically soccer games it's
not enough that the crowd is back in the
background it's not enough that you have
the two people basically um what's
expressive is the particular details of
how the work was composed okay and this
were this was composed sufficiently
differently I think that courts would
never find this to be an infringement
okay but but this is the closest they
would they were able to come but you can
imagine that the lawyers work really
really hard with the technologist to
find as close a match as they possibly
could what about the watermark what what
about the watermark does that hold on
hold on
geez
okay so now we get to the things about
the watermarks okay so 122 I mentioned
122 before intentionally removing or
altering copyright management
information knowing that the removal or
alteration can facilitate copyright
infringement that's
illegal uh Congress passed this law in
1998 uh at a time when there was concern
that what would happen is as the kind of
the digital market for copyrighted Goods
got going that people would put these
little watermarks on uh with a copyright
management information in it and
basically then hackers would be out
there and would take it out and then
substitute copyright management
information that was false in order to
basically then try to sell the thing the
counterfeit thing um uh uh for um as
though they're the copyright owner or
hackers might just liberate them pretend
that they're in the public domain and so
that was that's the concern that gave
rise to this particular legislation um
and the court recognize that it would be
difficult to measure actual damages for
the removal or alteration of the
copyright management information so they
created a statutory damage regime for it
uh so that every
violation um uh starts with a minimum of
$2500 uh statutory damage goes up to
$25,000 per violation and and the
complaint against
GitHub uses the 122 claims uh right so
um 5 billion lines of um of uh open
source code were used to train codex uh
so uh how many violations that might
that be um well you get to9 billion doar
pretty quickly um if you um uh say that
each one of those have copyright
management information removed and that
facilitated copyright infringement so
back to uh back to um uh this case so
you can see the Getty uh images logo
here that's the uh that's the Getty uh
photograph uh and you can see the
mangled stuff here okay so this kind of
looks like a alteration of copyright
management information and so uh again
stable diffusion uh may be in Greater um
or stability may be in Greater uh risk
of liability um than um the others but
uh that the copyright management
information claims in many of the
complaints anyway the point here is that
um generative AI is not the first
disruptive technology to have been um
sued
for uh for facilitating unauthorized
uses of copyrighted
Works uh video cassette report uh
recorders MP3 players and DVRs were also
sued and they all essentially got off
because the techn Technologies had
substantial non-infringing uses now just
because it's a a technology doesn't mean
necessarily that it's going to be okay
because groer and Napster for example
were held liable because they induced
infringers um to use them and uh so what
we have to say is the current copyright
uh litigation is very early stages I
don't happen to find the derivative work
or 122 claims persuasive but the
training data um ingestion issue um is
the what I when I and when I gave a talk
at the icml conference I call this the
Big Kahuna um this is the one that that
I think poses the greatest uh uh
challenge um uh but again to repeat you
guys really need to get your your act
together and uh and and submit things to
um uh the copyright office in response
to that notice of inquiry because um I
know people who are going to uh G to
submit comments and you wouldn't agree
with those comments so uh you you wanna
you want to make sure that your voices
are heard in this whole thing and again
I'm sorry I've going over a little bit
but um um but I think I answered a bunch
of questions
[Music]
on actually even though we have like 15
minute questions and then we'll have the
panel
yeah um yeah first thanks for wonderful
talk um I I want to ask a somewhat
different question which is um um you
know you spoke about the copyright law
as it is and what its implications are
for llms but could you say a little bit
about how copyright law should be
reimagined in the you know in the face
of llms in the sense that um um at least
from my KN Viewpoint copyright law is
intended to make it possible for people
to put their Creations out there
in in a way that you know and and it's
for society's benefit and so if you were
to reimagine what what would it look
like once we have llms and you know how
should how should the law be Rewritten
to make sure that there's another um
there's another kind of uh legal issue
that uh lots of people are exercised
about um and that I wrote something
about in
1985 um that is um who if anybody owns
the outputs of uh uh AI generated um
stuff and um uh the copyright office
official position right now is that uh
no copyright because there's no human
author right um and uh the fact that
somebody programmed it it's not enough
and uh the output is not um the
expression of an author and therefore
not protectable um and
um and so now if you create a work and
you try to register a claim of copyright
in it and it
contains uh AI generated stuff the
copyright office actually requires you
to
disclose um that this image or this text
actually was generated by the uh AI
system uh and you have to disclaim
authorship um back in the 1980s the last
time there was a big kind of like push
uh in Ai and everybody was excited and
the copyright people started getting
excited and that's why I wrote this
paper um
um uh UK basically passed a what they
what lawyers call A suig Generous an of
its own kind law it's kind of a little
mini copyright um for AI generated stuff
and so the UK actually has a law in
place now um there will be talk of
trying to do something like that and
there are also people trying to say Hey
you know this um uh this image that I
just created I used this set of prompts
so in fact I I I so carefully um
developed it that in fact I'm the author
and um a person named Chris kasanova um
is trying to get copyright uh
registration based on that now that
particular issue um uh is also in
litigation um the copyright office I
think is going to be upheld uh in its uh
in its position what would we do if we
were doing a blank SL Blank Slate um I'm
not sure um uh this actually sounds to
me like something where it would be a
good idea to get a lot of smart people
together and talk about it um and think
about sort of going forward what what do
we imagine the scenarios to be and what
would be a good way for copyright law to
evolve and are there other things that
you know there other governance
Frameworks that we should be thinking
about so um I think right now the kind
of the AI governance thing is over here
and copyright is over
here I think they actually have
something to do with each other um and
so but again we we only have this one
tool right now which is copyright and so
um that's the the that's the tool that
um the courts will have to they the
thing is that the court can't say well
this is a this is like a too
complicated go away um if the complaint
is
filed and the case doesn't get dismissed
outright judge doesn't have any choice
has to decide the case okay it's just
the way the world Works did you have
question I make a little follow a little
follow on comment to that I mean I think
because of this follow on to how might
you reimagine copyright because I mean I
think in the 21st century world it's not
only generative AI over here I think
there's also every young person right
that there's this kind of
new how young people think where what
you do is you take copyrighted works and
you do mashups you put various kinds of
filters over them and you post them on
Tik Tok right so like
generating derivative Works um is sort
of the new culture and so it sort of
seems in some sense that's in the same
space as what generative AI is doing but
human done which again sort of suggests
like maybe we do need a new basis yeah
well so what has happened um in the
Digital World um is that copyright law
has had to kind of just get a grip and
so you know would the would the kind of
the big content owners would they like
to be able to um to control the entire
space the answer is yes um but they
basically say okay I don't really like
fanfiction but you know what fanfiction
actually builds a fan base and maybe I
should just relax about that and what I
should focus on more is the people who
are counterfeits right and so um
the the the law has had to
get
more flexible
uh because otherwise we'd be throwing
everybody in jail um and so peer-to-peer
file sharing another example is like
millions and millions of people did it
um it's kind of illegal um but um uh you
know nobody went to jail for it um and
you know there were a couple of lawsuits
about it but not very many and you know
somehow what happens of course is that
the market economy basically took care
of it right when you have things like uh
Spotify and apple music and so forth you
know it's uh less risky if you use one
of these services and they're sensibly
priced you know the only reason Apple
was able to get into this Market was
because of peer-to-peer file sharing so
hey why don't you guys want to make a
little bit of money here um and so um
that but the pricing and the way that
they that it was structured uh is
definitely um the result of of per of
the PE peer-to-peer file sharing sorry
take two three more questions then we'll
have a panel you can ask more
questions um I have a question about the
difference between use uh of data in the
training or a work in the training data
and generating some output so if we know
that there's some uh copyrighted work in
the training data but we could prove
maybe empirically or mathematically that
it's not used in a particular generation
of of an output are we kind of
safe yeah I mean the the truth is that
the the courts don't understand the
technology they really don't um so one
of the things that people in your field
are going to have to get good at is
translating of what is going on under
the hood so that the courts basically
don't say oh here's the and here's the
training data um and here's the output
and oh there are some similarities here
therefore there must be infringing
derivative work so the stuff under the
hood is the stuff that uh as you suggest
May in fact be very useful to say hey
this in fact is not uh is not an
infringement because I can prove it
mathematically and you know Court kind
of like math and so I think that would
probably
work yeah uh with this point about how
equations can't be artistic
I'm I'm wondering I'm wondering if
there's something deep here okay so I
once had a student who cheated on an
exam right and I brought it to the dean
and like here you see the two answers
you see that they're like word for word
the same you know except the variable
names right and and I got back a very
interesting answer which is well this is
a math problem of course there's only
one right answer and you know I had to
explain okay but you know there are
exponentially many different ways of
expressing you know what the true answer
is so you know in this ho case that you
talked about like was it actually a word
for word copy no um it was um the I mean
the equations were um were exact um and
the figures as I understand it were
exact but um I don't I don't know enough
about what the text was but I would
guess that um probably tavla smart
enough to not use exactly the same words
okay but um you know paraphrasing can
also be uh an infringement yeah okay one
more question
then I'm sorry if this is a repeat of a
question let's say You're really really
good at prompt
engineering putting in many I would just
say artistic elements to how to ask your
AI to do something but that because it's
generated by AI that would not be
copyrighted at this point at this point
yeah okay
thank you I mean as I said um Chris
kasanova uh has uh essentially been
trying to make the case uh that um that
this long series of prompts uh yielded
what in fact was her vision uh of the of
the work and the court um uh or the sort
of the copyright office basically said
no um but um there's kind of a
recognition that maybe right so
cashanova is trying again and so we'll
see what what happens with that the
copyright office is just going to have
to make a lot of very very fine detailed
um uh distinctions between this thing
and that
thing okay we're going to move on to a
panel so please the panelist uh take
your
seats